oggi si parla di sostenibilità Certo
però non vi voglio portare il solito
pessimismo apocalittico anche se ce ne
sarebbero tutte le ragioni
oggi vi voglio raccontare una storia che
possa farvi sentire
forti e coraggiosi rispetto a quello che
probabilmente è il Challenge più grande
che l'umanità si sia mai trovata ad
affrontare
la storia inizia nel 2017 la mia prima
startup era appena fallita
io ho studiato design industriale e era
un designer e in quel momento mi
ritrovavo a fare il contabile il manager
di un piccolo Hotel Nella campagna
inglese Non era esattamente il momento
più alto della mia carriera come potete
immaginare
e quindi penso mi serve una via d'uscita
Mi serve una scappatoia e penso a una
soluzione di design per rendere più
funzionale e più sostenibile la scarpa
quello che probabilmente l'elemento più
impattante del nostro guardaroba e del
settore Fashion ma vi do due due numeri
sul settore del Fashion il Fashion oggi
produce il 10%
della CO2 globale e la scarpa è
realmente l'elemento più inquinante del
nostro guardaroba Perché rispetto alla
maglietta una giacca a dei pantaloni a
un vestito la scarpa è fatta di una
miriade di diversi materiali 28 e più
componenti coinvolge processi
industriali altamente energivori come lo
stampaggio delle suole materiali
plastici
quindi penso penso alla fine arriva
l'idea è una scarpa modulare
in cui mantenendo la stessa suola tu
stacchi la parte di sopra e la puoi
cambiare puoi costruire 3 5 10 paia di
scarpe con una sola suola
quindi la in quel momento nasce
ac/dc anything can be Change tutto si
può cambiare
creiamo il video lo mettiamo su
kickstarter kickstarter è una
piattaforma fondamentalmente dove voi
potete mettere un prodotto e fare dei
preordini prima che il prodotto sia
realizzato
mettiamo il video su kickstarter il
video fa 50 milioni di visualizzazioni e
raccogliamo un milione di euro di
preordini da privati in tutto il mondo
Quindi tutto va alla grande no Apriamo
distribuzione in Asia distribuzione in
Europa Il Brand sta andando alla grande
ma luglio del 2019 mi rendo conto che
sta per succedere qualcosa che cambierà
radicalmente il nostro mondo è estate fa
caldo tutti Sono super tranquilli No
sotto l'ombrellone a godersela io apro
il mio giornale e leggo questo articolo
e l'articolo era del Centro nazionale
per la ricerca sul clima australiano e
l'articolo dice il punto di non ritorno
punto di rottura per tutti i nostri
ecosistemi non è il 2100 Come da
precedenti ricerca il 2050 Se non
riduciamo le emissioni del 70% tra il
2020 e il 2030 Io penso ci schiantiamo
sicuramente qua perché nessuno gliene
frega niente stanno tutti tranquilli
sotto l'ombrellone ci andiamo a
schiantare
per il conto mio Io ovviamente comincio
a fare ricerca su materiali cerco di
rendere più sostenibile possibile il
prodotto che facevamo no
novembre di quell'anno rilanciamo di
nuovo su kickstarter stessa piattaforma
la versione diciamo del primo prodotto
che WWE una dei media più importanti del
nostro settore
WWE definisce come la scarpa più
sostenibile del mondo Io penso Vabbè
spacchiamo se il primo prodotto ha fatto
uno questo farà due
lanciamo il video tutti i carichi
indovinate cosa succede flop totale
il progetto non raccoglie neanche
€10.000 Ma lo sapete perché perché
fondamentalmente prima del covip
la sostenibilità veniva utilizzata solo
come strumento di marketing era uno
strumento per pulire l'immagine
dell'azienda e fare un bel Green washing
e la gente si era stufata La gente non è
stupida si era rotta le scatole di
sentir parlare di sostenibilità bene un
mese un paio di mesi dopo quel flop
Indovina indovinate cosa succede arriva
il covid quindi mi chiama il mio socio
mi fa Edoardo noi tra sei mesi chiudiamo
falliamo su Porca miseria tragico
momento ovviamente tragico però il covid
non è stato sulla tragedia realmente per
il nostro mondo per il mondo della
sostenibilità
è stato uno spartiacque prima del covid
la sostenibilità era solamente un
argomento di marketing dopo il covi
della sostenibilità si sposta su un
piano scientifico
sempre più aziende del mio settore del
settore del Fashion cominciano ad
allinearsi ai Science base targets
cominciano allinearsi
a obiettivi di riduzione scientifici del
50% della CO2 entro 2030
Quindi ovviamente per noi sono momenti
tragici perché noi stiamo per fallire ma
in quel momento pensiamo e capiamo che
il mondo non aveva bisogno dell'ennesimo
Brandy calzature i Brand i famosi Brand
che producevano producono il 10% della
CO2 globale avevano promesso di ridurre
del 50% il loro impatto entro il 2030
ovviamente quei Brand avevano bisogno di
soluzioni e per obiettivi scientifici
servono soluzioni scientifiche
quindi in quel momento
io ho coraggio e mi sposto
dalla sfera del design a studiare metodi
di analisi e calcolo dell'impatto
ambientale
sposto la mia creatività e mi concentro
su innovazioni di tecnologie di
materiali e processi industriali che
possano ridurre quell'impatto e quindi
ac/dc da Brand diventa ac/dc metod ci
inventiamo un metodo proprietario per
trasformare materiali prodotti processi
e Fabbriche
con il dato e l'esperienza
quindi Trasformiamo alla fine i prodotti
e le fabbriche di questi Brand ma adesso
vi racconto un attimo come funziona
Allora l'ac/dc metodo adesso diciamo vi
faccio un racconto di come funziona le
ac/dctod quando Trasformiamo un prodotto
prendiamo il prodotto esitis così com'è
lo analizziamo
calcolando tutti gli input energetici
lungo il suo ciclo di vita
dall'estrazione delle materie prime ai
processi di lavorazione di queste al
trasporto interno di questa la fabbrica
dove vengono assemblate i processi di
assemblaggio la logistica Al magazzino
la fase di utilizzo e la fine è il fine
vita tutti gli input energetici in
questo ciclo di vita danno come
risultato l'output di anidride carbonica
di quel prodotto la CO2 del prodotto
la seconda fase è la fase di
trasformazione Trasformiamo materiali
convenzionali con materiali circolari
provenienti da fonti riciclate o
biobased accorciamo la filiera riduciamo
l'impatto durante la produzione e
l'assemblaggio
bene penserete che è una fase
divertente No è una fase molto delicata
Perché quando noi fondamentalmente
Trasformiamo un prodotto Cambiamo i suoi
materiali insieme una riduzione di
impatto misurabile
dobbiamo ovviamente rispettare obiettivi
del Brand obiettivi di procurvent
servizio tempi di consegna costo design
il look ovviamente deve essere approvato
dal team dei designer
e ultimo ma sicuramente non ultimo per
importanza la resistenza fisica la
durabilità del prodotto è probabilmente
la caratteristica più importante di un
prodotto che possa ritenersi più
sostenibile
terza fase fondamentalmente tutti i
materiali che hanno passato questo
processo e sono stati promossi passano
dal prodotto pilota a essere estesi in
tutte le collezioni del Brand diventano
strumenti di lavoro dei Team di
produzione in questo modo da un progetto
fondamentalmente da un prodotto pilota
Creiamo un improvement un miglioramento
che diventa integrale all'organizzazione
che diventa profondo e orizzontale
oggi
da due fondatori che abbiamo iniziato
oggi siamo in 35 a Milano
e supportiamo la trasformazione di 45
Brand tra cui ci sono aziende quotate
aziende enormi leader di settore ma il
motivo per cui Queste aziende realmente
ci seguono e ci ascoltano non è
probabilmente solo la nostra competenza
il nostro metodo proprietario e la
nostra professionalità e anche l'energia
e la positività che ci mettiamo
nell'abbracciare il cambiamento
Adesso vi voglio lasciare con uno spunto
con un aneddoto che una cosa che è
successa una settimana fa Infatti
l'organizzatore del 13 Ma come ha
iniziato è successo una settimana fa il
discorso l'hai preparato da mesi e vabbè
c'è questa news Allora una settimana fa
la manager di uno dei Brand che seguiamo
che supportiamo e mi fa Edoardo Ma come
facciamo a ridurre i nostri impatti del
50%
se Dobbiamo raddoppiare la produzione
del doppio entro il 2030 e li faccio è
impossibile
è impossibile
e vi chiedo Ma secondo voi basta
cambiare le tecnologie dei materiali
processi e le tecnologie per riuscire a
raggiungere i nostri obiettivi di
riduzione a livello globale e contenere
le temperature l'alzamento delle
temperature sotto gli 1,5 o i due gradi
No la risposta è no
non basta non basta non basta cambiare
gli impatti all'interno delle nostre
azioni
oggi ci dicono continua a consumare come
hai sempre fatto Vai tranquillo Basta
che compri i prodotti sostenibili che
dopo li ricicli no non basta bisogna non
basta ridurre gli impatti all'interno
delle stazioni bisogna ridurre le azioni
stesse
quante cose oggi noi facciamo e
compriamo che non sono realmente
essenziali bisogna ripensare a quali
sono le cose essenziali farli durare il
più possibile e solo alla fine
tirare in mezzo la circolarità
e quindi Signori io vi dico
perché sono un ottimista Ce la faremo ce
la faremo ma ce la faremo solo se
insieme all'innovazione tecnologica
Avremo anche un innovazione valoriale e
ce la faremo solo se tutti noi avremo il
coraggio di abbracciare il cambiamento e
di applicare alla vita di tutti i giorni
i concetti di essenzialità
longevità è solo alla fine ma quando
alla fine sarà Inevitabile di
circolarità
Grazie
[Applauso]